[Music]
interesting scenario that the coin has
been tossed and smearing has the white
pieces and amazingly enough Danny this
is the repetition of what happened in
Moscow the players were even after the
first two games and now again smearin
has the white pieces as he did then anon
the black pieces at a benign brought the
game he wins the match that's right but
smearing has a time of on teachers of
one minute time advantage to compensate
for that so it's all down to this game
Marin opens with his favorite efore move
and Anand playing symmetrically for the
moment smearing lashing out with his
pawn so this is a typical opening that
r9 uses he's used it in many big time
competitions he's won a lot of games
with it and now just playing quickly all
he needs to do is draw and he'll move on
to the next round
Kasparov or wait to the winner so that's
a slight surprise and I'm thinking about
this move slightly unusual now what's he
going to play never seen an iron so
uncertain it's incredible he's spending
a lot of time in his Calaca need to
remember that he's spotting smear in a
minute and for him to be thinking this
deeply and it's only like the fourth the
fourth move on the board is incredible
spoon playing very cleverly here now
what's he gonna do I thinking I think
this is unbelievably zall most spent a
minute how many 20 percent of his time
for four moves it's incredible the
uncertainty of this strong player he
clearly is a bit off form he better get
back in force he's gonna be out of this
competition he's on the four minutes now
it's crazy what inaudible converse you
make a movie come move madness come on
this is this is unbelievable this this
is shocking I'm stunned to see it he's
thinking this long on this the fourth
move of the chess game analyzing what I
do not know but a smearing has
successfully thrown him off and now he's
used a minute and parity
is to think about four moves this is
completely ridiculous he's putting
himself into a deep deep hole yeah I
mean this this simple recapture of the
porn by white is a little bit unusual
normally you attack this night first
having said that the position is fairly
simple
what is Vichy day finally made a move I
mean could could it have been that
dramatic I do not know what he was
thinking about but it's certainly
surprising he spent all that time and
finally is chase tonight although
although he's renowned to be an
incredible speed player we've seen him
uncertain in this match he needs to get
his form back and he's lost a lot of
time in the clock and he needs to start
whipping out some moves and finally he's
pushed his point up and now he's
beginning to play a little bit quicker
the bishop attacking it now his night
has come out into the game and now he's
speeding up the king is castled so this
is a fairly well known position but
Anand is used to almost two minutes to
get that I still don't know what he was
doing so that he's played this way
before this is a known theoretical
position so and I noticed it very well
but he's he's moving he's used a lot of
time on his clock is used a lot of time
and and now he's under three minutes and
smearin has not even used one minute
he's not even used 60 seconds on his
plot and none already used about two and
two minutes 15 seconds so the time could
be a crucial factor here Anna's position
is fine very soild reasonable he has
great experience with this opening but
he's down on time he's exchanging our
pieces now if Knight has to drop back
and his drop back to the center the
knight kicking at this Bishop so let's
let's suppose he wants to save that
bishop well then he'll have to drop it
back one square he doesn't want to do
that he's left sit along Marian
increasing the pressure now this Knight
is stopping this attack down towards the
king the Queen bishop in a very Spratt
nning battery down here so the pawn has
come up he's taken oh this is fantastic
he's taking this point sacrificing a
piece and
smearin has collected another porn it
seems as if he thought he was going to
win this night button on has defended it
quite simply with this Bishop move and
maybe smearing is going to be down a
piece okay but smearing has two points
for this piece and he's now got a third
so he has three pawns for the piece
that's compensation itself I can't help
but think though that an island of peace
is a lot more confident he's starting to
move like his old self
he's gotten the challenge and he's going
to try to meet it moving much quicker
moving his king now of that dangerous
deadly diagonal he's put it in the
corner hiding it and he has a piece but
as you said Danny three pawns for it is
what White has yeah but I mean I would
still prefer I would prefer White's
position here definitely and at least
Anand has something to go for now it's
fairly clear where his chances lie so
he's down on time but he's got something
to play for now he's whipping off moves
as suddenly a pause in the situation
look at some earrings bishop despite
being a piece down he has some healthy
bishops sitting in the middle of the
board and he's attacking a point and
anon has ignored it this is why they
call this a shootout both sides guns
come out blazing and now making sure
that no attack happens an anon and
sacrificed the bishop in the middle but
of course he was gaining that Queen and
he sacrificed his room his rook for the
bishop and now he's attacking he's
attacking a rook and a queen this is
fantastic battle going on the reason
he's done that is to trade off pieces
there you go he's just trading more
pieces of the board and it seems he's
about to win not just one pawn but -
he's ripping a rook - no in fact he's
only going to win one pawn and he's up a
piece and Danny this is like a quick
turnaround and Ana's us up a piece okay
he's on the piece but he speaking for
fantastic it sacrificed his Queen and
only verbal sacrifice a non showing his
form so at the start of this smearing
had three points for the piece now he's
only got one fish fish he has a clearly
winning position here only problem is
time
he has about a minute in the house try
and win this game smearing has over
three minutes and look at a nine
displayed his skill his accuracy in his
moves moving quickly showing just why
they consider him so fast and so rich a
speed player he's just moving quickly
now he's had a big disadvantage on the
clock but he's got an extra piece but
this this is not over yet this game is
not over and and has only a mere knocked
try and win this game but look at that
position the piece is all and he [ __ ]
that rope down with authority and pàmies
ripped off all the extra points he's
just got a past point and look at him
make a minute look like a year he's
ripped another point off the board